which season is this this is incredible
to me its head yeah this is season five
incredible success with this show people
absolutely love it
Carrie you're in drag a lot on the show
and when you're in drag people have
started to notice that you look exactly
like the actor Justin Long yes I think
we have a picture here
which was I guess not intentional right
yeah there was just a nice discovery it
was a nice discovery yeah for both of us
for both yeah yeah and Justins on the
show this year oh he's cut he's coming
on the show and you're gonna make use of
the fact that you look a lot like each
other with yes we've absolutely made use
of that fact very nice Fred I'm told
that you like to act in an obnoxious
manner in order to annoy Carey yeah
lives together it well in the scenes
when we do this show I think that I I
feel like we get the best out of the
scenes if i annoy carry all the way
through so like if I'm just doesn't
sound like anything that would help any
people do a scene you know it's worked
out yeah you know and I just do stuff
where I like I think that I'm
intelligent and I'm very clearly not so
that that's I think of what it has
worked out the best wait is this real
life or on the show I can't remember in
real life I'm actually and I'm not
bragging I'm quite intelligent
that's true you know quite and no I
meant like on the show like I'm yeah
sketches and stuff so and how does that
manifest itself you're in a scene
together and you just start saying
things that you think sound really smart
yeah like there's that one character you
know we do where I'm just like doing a
lot of philosophy and a lot of people
will notice that many of the trees in
this area and that like that kind of
like I'm about to go into a lecture so I
just like to to see Kerry fall apart
during that and you'd annoys you because
you were you're a big reader aren't you
I am a big reader and we fed was in that
character all day one day and actually
the crew we all were annoyed at Fred
okay Fred it was it's a rideshare it's a
rideshare we're forced to be in a car
for a long time yeah and you will see
strange you will stay in character all
day pretty much yeah it's an all evasion
what about when you gave me whiplash in
another scene okay
you really gave yeah yeah I I still feel
really really bad about it we did the
scene where I play a driver I play a
driver whose drives too slow right I'm
too careful so I kept pumping the brakes
off not pumping slamming on the other
bit
I am really sorry I'm saying to you here
yeah I'm really really sorry about that
I it was just unexpected and I really
slammed hard on it and she was really
upset he's like you don't understand how
car cars work
I do now now Kerry you have ways of
getting Fred back is that correct like
for example your scream your scream has
a certain effect on Fred yes a certain
effect do you want do you want to hear
that it she has the the most effective
scream ever it is it is really piercing
I'm not sure I want to hear that now
what so you do a scream and what effect
does it have on you does it startle you
it startles me at first I'm a little
scared
and then I laugh afterwards it's like a
frightened because of how scared I was
I mean I'm laughing because I'm how
scared I was Kerry I think you should go
for it okay I should say that it's
usually a in relation to a character
you're led preemptively plugging your
ears
come here should man up and just get
over here all right well okay so if I
was Cathy by you know out of nowhere no
that's it is a surprise when you do it
it's part of the character though yes
but it always surprises me it surprises
me when you're annoying Andy this became
a couple's yeah this is dr. Isis dr.
Phil all of a sudden that makes well
that makes me feel like what I hear what
I hear you saying can I talk no it
well I think both of you have to buy a
knob
[Applause]
you